Cody Fisher was a young footballer who
was on a night out with friends when he
was stabbed to death
he was on the dance floor in a nightclub
in Birmingham when he was attacked
at his Club Stratford town the players
and chairman are in Shock he's a
talented footballer but more importantly
he was a lovely person he was just a
lovely lady cheeky smile on his face in
that blonde hair blue eyes he didn't
have a bad bone such a good kid
shouldn't have happened yet
foreign
and they just need a chance don't they
and then they
they go out
Pharmacy and they don't come home
it's got a change in it
it's got to change
pictures from inside the crane nightclub
in digbeth show a packed Dance Floor on
boxing day night it was that the evening
was coming to an end that Cody was
fatally stabbed
staff described Mayhem as people ran out
of the club officers were called at
quarter to midnight but Cody was
pronounced dead around half an hour
later
there were hundreds of people in this
nightclub and police say they want to
speak to anyone who saw what happened or
has footage on their mobile phones
some people who were at the club have
described seeing a group of young men
who were looking for trouble other
clubbers have criticized Security checks
at the event police say Cody was
approached by a group of people and then
stabbed but no one knows why he was
targeted one of his family has paid
tribute saying they have broken our
hearts I've lost my best friend my
family and I are asking for privacy and
respectfulness at this heartbreaking
time
the nightclub say their thoughts are
with the victim and his family and
friends an ad that they're working
closely with West Midlands police
they've canceled their event on New
Year's Eve
the football clubs where Cody has played
over the years have all been sharing
their shock and sadness this promising
young footballer now the latest innocent
victim of Senseless violence
Becky Johnson Sky News Birmingham